[Applause]
an explosion of relief
and celebration after what scientists
describe as
seven minutes of terror
watching their spacecraft land on mars
the mission is a success china's venture
to the red planet is its most ambitious
space mission yet
before now it's only gone as far as the
moon
it should be said that this was not an
easy task it is our first time down this
path
and we have met many difficulties it was
through a lot of hard work that today
we were able to go through with our
plans to make our goals a reality
the tianwen one orbiter set out in july
last year
and reached mars in seven months it's
been circling the red planet
since february the six-wheeled rover
inside
jurong is named after the god of fire in
ancient chinese mythology
the plan is for jurong to undergo a few
days of tests
before it explores an icy area known as
utopia planishia
joining an american rover that landed in
february
it's going to look at the geology of the
area look for evidence of past water
current water
study the interior of mars they've got a
really ambitious program of science
particularly like say for the first time
that they've been to mars they're kind
of trying to do everything all at once
confirmed perseverance faithfully on the
surface of mars
china is now the third country to make a
touchdown on mars
after russia in 1971 and the u.s five
years later
nasa's rovers have already sent back
pictures of their environment
the sound of the martian wind while a
tiny helicopter ingenuity
made a pioneering flight there last
month
several other craft are orbiting the
planet including one from the united
arab emirates
part of a global space race that's
recently accelerated
with several countries jostling for the
top spot
china's efforts haven't been without
criticism
last week it caused concern worldwide
when debris from one of its rockets fell
to earth
uncontrolled the u.s space agency nasa
accused beijing of being irresponsible
though china said there was only an
extremely
low risk of damage but in the long term
china's
looking in a very similar way to the us
of sending people out into space so for
scientists it's really exciting because
of
the things we can learn but i think
societally it's also really cool because
it's a step along the road to actually
human exploration
and a permanent presence for people in
space beyond the earth
another successful mars mission that
could have long-term consequences
for those of us on this planet alexia
o'brien al jazeera